ok ça lui youtube ok là j'ai un micro de
ces prêts nouveaux micros je ressens
d'être un mec de la radio tu es comment
ça va bien venu dans cette émission
écoutez les auditeurs qui nous écoutent
savent très bien à quel point le régime
politique en place
j'ai l'impression ce qui me gêne dans
micro c'est que quand je fais
oui j'ai un côté où on entend beaucoup
plus du coup je vais tourner la tête ya
des moments où ça est plus forte
je sais pas je m'en rends pas compte on
verra au montage et comment ça va ça
fait un bail les gars ça fait très
longtemps tapi 13 ans après à la fois
que j'ai parlé sur youtube
c'était il ya un mois je vous ai sorti
cette vidéo
changement d'opinion illustré en 40
secondes où je disais que ça faisait
longtemps que j'avais pas manger de
viande
il ya plein de gens qui n'ont pas
compris j'avoue moi même j'ai pas
compris
j'ai fait cette vidéo je me suis dit ça
m'arrange concernant vidéo de 46
secondes comme ça voilà du coup et ça
faisait longtemps qu'on n'était pas
parlé je vais très bien je vous remercie
vous merci mépriser la question c'est
cool c'est gentil j'espère que vous
aussi j'espère que vous avez passé un
très bon été moi je passe un très bel
été je vous ai préparé
plein de petites choses et dans les
petites choses que je vous ai préparé il
ya des choses que je vous ai préparé
depuis fort longtemps j'ai pas pourquoi
je partais dans un accent mais en gros
dans un truc que je vous ai préparé
depuis fort longtemps il ya un projet
genre c'est de refaire plus d'un an
qu'il est juste cette chaise grince
j'entendais le grincement de cette
chaise ou pas chaises qui m'a été
offerte par le space paris pour la bonne
raison que j'arrivais très souvent en
retard au tournage gagné le prix du mec
le plus en retard et du coup mon fils et
cette chaise donc papa maman c'était
juste pour vous dire que vous voyez le
fait d'être en retard tout temps ma vie
bah ça m'a servi au moins une fois à
gagner une chaise voilà donc je vous
disais c'est un projet énorme depuis
longtemps mais au lieu de tergiverser
au lieu de vous parler des heures d'un
truc qui abstrait je vous montre tout de
suite un extrait un extrait d'une minute
c'est parti
[Musique]
jusqu'ici le désir nous a semblé être un
truc négatif qu'il faut maîtriser voire
supprimés mais si on essayait de voir en
lui une puissance créatrice qui nous
projette au devant nous même si ce café
rousseau par exemple dit dans julie ou
la nouvelle héloïse malheur à qui n'a
plus rien à désirer
cela veut dire que le bonheur vient non
pas du fait d' obtenir ce qu'on désire
mais de l'action même de désiré désirer
c'est vrai c'est ressentir un manque qui
va créer de la peine mais ce manque
diot désir ce n'est pas forcément un
problème pour l'homme au contraire pour
rousseau l'état de désiré se suffit à
lui-même
ça veut dire que le but du désir n'est
pas d'obtenir l'objet qu'il convoite
mais de désirer tout simplement quand on
désire on est heureux et envoie devant
nous un bonheur possible rousseau va
même jusqu'à dire que le moment du désir
provoque la jouissance et qu'il est
encore plus fort que le moment où la
souris c'est notre imagination qui fait
que l'on est heureux qu'avant d'être
heureux quand on désire quelque chose on
l'idéalisé quand tu penses à tes
prochaines vacances
tu te dis que ça va être la folie
piscine soleil soirée et tout c'est là
que ton bonnet a le plus fort car sur
place si tu compares le réel est ce que
tu as à imaginer battait souvent déçu
[Musique]
vacances de merde super génial ce que
vous venez de voir ça s'appelle
l'antisèche donc là vous venez voir une
vidéo de philo donc sur le programme de
terminale l'antisèche c'est un projet
global transverses donc qui va parler de
toutes les matières et traiter le
programme du brevet et du bac toutes les
vidéos elles ont été faites en
collaboration avec des profs je vais sur
la chaîne l'antisèche côté je pourrais
vous montrer ma bonne dame a même times
voilà est reparti en externe donc la
voilà la chaîne elle est sortie hier il
ya déjà 3500 abonnés donc un grand merci
à vous un grand merci à tous ceux qui
ont partagé mon post sur facebook
je crois que vous êtes 13 merci beaucoup
un grand merci à tous ceux qui ont
retweeté mon tweet vous êtes plus de
2000 merci beaucoup merci pour tous vos
messages sur ce match at voilà merci j'y
reviendrai mais tout ça pour dire donc
là la chaîne elle est sortie il ya une
vidéo d'économie ya une vidéo sur la
philo via une vidéo sur l'histoire avec
les tranchées ya une vidéo sur les maths
avec les puissances et vidéo sur la
cartographie et miso sur la physique la
lumière blanche
c'est un projet fat va y avoir genre une
vidéo par semaine va y avoir plus d'une
centaine je pense de vidéos dans l'année
donc ça fait plus d'une vidéo par
semaine en fait champion de me dire aux
africains et en vidéo un gros merci aux
profs qui ont fait un travail formidable
là dessus vous avez été ou seront
remerciés à mon pote de toujours comme
ça a été mon gars sur et qui a du coup
retravaillé tous les textes des profs et
ses draps pour les rendre plus digeste
avant que moi je repasse derrière je
pense que c'est un projet qui est utile
à la société
vraiment je suis allé jusque là parce
que bah c'est une offre de soutien
scolaire gratos en ligne voilà hyper
accessible avec un vrai travail de
vulgarisation et tous qui reprend les
codes de youtube
donc voilà ça me fait graver plaisir
c'est un projet je voulais faire depuis
longtemps tout seul clairement c'est
impossible parce que c'est trop gros
j'ai des potes qui avait la même volonté
on sait match et et genre sacré
l'antisèche c'est un petit bébé
voilà c'était un peu à ma couche
première fois donc allez-y
abonnez-vous et surtout si vous êtes en
course vous êtes
au lycée que vous êtes au collège
parlez-en à toute votre classe par
exemple tout le monde
si vous n'êtes pas en cours vous n'êtes
pas au collège et que vous êtes police
est honnie au lycée et que vous avez
d'un petite soeur un petit frère qui au
collège au lycée
parlez-en dit que louis saha s'est fait
tourner fait tourner là c'est le moment
là ces moments où j'ai en moi j'ai fait
tout ce que je pouvais faire d'amd taf
là c'est le moment où se lancer le plus
la balle est dans votre camp voilà
c'était la principale chose que je
voulais vous annoncer aujourd'hui c'est
un voilà encore une fois c'est un très
beau projet mais tu es un projet aussi
gros de ma vie merci youtube merci vous
parce que c'est vous qui m'avez fait
confiance et vous qui m'avez amenée
jusqu'ici et c'est vous qui avez fait en
sorte qu'il ya d'autres gens qui me font
confiance et que j'ai pu créer ce truc
là non plus donc merci à eux je pense
que j'ai tout dit janvier j non j'ai pas
dit mot extincteur ça j'ai pas dis je
crois que j'ai tout dit abonne toi
abonne toi l'antisèche même si tu passes
pas le bac ou le brevet il ya plein de
vidéos qui peuvent intéresser genre les
vidéos sur les tranchées dans j'ai
enchaîné des rimes là en impro là je
suis assez chaud je voulais aussi vous
dire que la chaîne va reprendre une
publication normale très très bientôt
voilà il ya des vidéos qui vont sortir
la très très vite là y'en a une soeur
dimanche 2 qui sort la semaine prochaine
normalement je fais beaucoup bisous je
vous aime très très fort bisous